there are so many other games command
2016 and I know the ones i'm excited for
primarily Last Guardian I am super
curious how he was gonna turn out after
a decade I don't think it's gonna I
don't know that it's going to be amazing
but I know that I'm endlessly curious
Final Fantasy 15 as well but what about
you guys what's the stuff you're looking
forward to the rest of the year um I'm
curious to see what battlefield is like
and as well as titanfall I'm actually
super excited to play that campaign
having like seen snippets of it I'm sure
you got you saw some of it it looks
great looks like it's just it feels like
a perfect example of a developer that
saw all the feedback and was like okay
we'll just do that we'll take all the
feedback on like there was much of a
story I didn't understand like it they
had every like they hit every mark with
developing that like Titan pilot
relationship that just seems so strong
and then some of the footage we've seen
looks real like I'm really excited for
that and to know more about that
universe because it's a sweet universe
but that campaign we just didn't might
be about a hard time of you know
intertwining that with multiplayer like
you're just so distracted so yeah this
that's I think that's really exciting
but unfortunately that those are
basically in the same what two weeks one
week now filled in time fourth pretty
close yeah not far both both due out
this month this month particular is
really intense but yeah I mean I
actually got to play a few hours of a
two or two or three hours of titan falls
campaign and and yeah I mean I the year
your perception is is very right they
dug into the story they've really
fleshed out the relationship between one
particular pilot and tighten actually I
think that the most surprising thing
about my time with the single player was
the fact that you have dialogue options
yeah constantly your bantering with your
Titan BTW or just either over the radio
or like while you're piloting him and
like he just kind of ways in with stuff
like as you're moving to level and you
can choose how you respond you be kind
of snarky or you can like be nice about
things and it doesn't really direct the
story in any way it's just kind of
allowing you to shape that friendship or
that partnership in a way that reflects
kind of your
personality you know I thought that was
kind of a cool choice this is gun in
there for some flavor just keeps you
engaged yeah actly actually am I in my
am i right about the Sinclair I compared
it to fire watch which is the closest
thing I could think of that it's not so
much about you know you unlock a
different ending if you direct the
narrative down this path it's just you
were kind of shaping a relationship
which is really cool I think they
actually have done a pretty good job
with that that portion of the writing
was really good and also and from what I
saw as well was you know taking
different directions of like are you
more into the humor side of a story to
be told yeah choose that path or you
want to know maybe you want to know more
specifics or more more details it seemed
like they were kind of directing those
choices in that direction yeah I don't
think it runs super deep but you
definitely have some degree of control
over how you engage the world for sure
yeah so I'm I'm pretty psyched about the
campaign and actually I've really
enjoyed multiplayer as well I know
people weren't weren't super stoked on
the beta but I've now also played like
the full competitive suite with all of
the titans in it and a whole bunch of
new maps and modes and stuff and it all
kind of comes together in an interesting
way Rob and I have talked about this
before so honestly I'm pretty psyched
about titanfall I know people are a
little cold on it after having played
the beta but I'm I'm site I having now
played quite a bit of it I'm very
excited same thing with gears actually
played a lot of gears I think that's
coming together really well I really
like the direction the team is taking it
seems like they have a firm
understanding of the franchise and know
when to defer to the legacy of the game
and went to kind of push things in a new
direction I had a lot of fun playing the
campaign it felt very much like a gears
campaign of like you know this mix of
very linear corridor shooting that then
opens up into a broader arena and then
like you are you encounter a set-piece
moment and everything is paced very
deliberately and it's very cinematic and
you get these you know relationship
moments between the characters it's all
very very gears and seemed to be pretty
well executed at least a portion that I
play it and then multiplayer as well
drawing a lot from gears past but doing
new things with it like super fun I much
to do in a stream of the horde mode
tomorrow so people want to tune in horde
mode as a ton of fun I really like what
they've done with that so gears is like
god I think it comes out next week right
cheese yeah
so I'm psyched for Gears I'm hoping it's
going to be as good as the portions that
I've played so far about watch dogs to
rob you grew up in San Francisco does
that appeal to you at all playing a game
like that's supposed to be realized the
city like that well and by such depth
yeah you know I looked at some of the
absolutely like I would definitely see
some of the landmarks like the bush guy
oh you see in that he is and supposedly
unfortunately he actually died in real
life or her I know yeah so people who
don't know the bush guy is person down
by the pier who would hide behind a
swath of bush and jump out and scare
unsuspecting tourists much to the
delight of everyone else but those
tourists yeah and this for years old
years yep he's great he's in the game
which i think is great look what on
YouTube yeah you know I think it's it's
cool you know they got an office out
here like I think they're gonna do the
city justice I think they're gonna show
it well my main concern and I think it
looks like they really stepped it up was
for me watchdogs one I got unfortunately
like three hours in yeah and literally
lost a craving battle for GTA like
literally will it put that game down and
would like play GTA 5 because that open
world for me and then driving and you
just I feel like it was just not
clicking like it wasn't believable the
open world people walking around
chatting like it just like nothing sold
me as well as like I kinda thought oh
game however this time around it looked
like they've really gone into the
direction of like you know what we're
just gonna give you all these great
abilities like you know you could
basically frame a police officer on the
street and say he's a wanted murderer
and all the couple turn their guns on
and like I feel like they were done a
nice job of just like giving you all the
tools to like have fun but not
necessarily saying like this is crave
emailing me like not taking the route of
say like a saints row where it's like
overly just like sarcastic almost I
don't know right and this just seems a
more enjoyable world to display in it
looks good the footage looks good I'm I
got my hopes for that she seems fun like
now it's kind of what was missing from
the first game it was so like even the
hero is just this dour
humorless jerk he was just I mean in a
sense in the story context is he lost it
family and there's this redemption story
but the entire game felt so gray and
self serious that it really was just
kind of missing fun and so I feel like
this this new world in this new city and
you set a new character all kind of have
at least a degree of fun to it that
makes you kind of want to spend time
there i'm a little worried that they're
gonna go too over the top with like the
millennial flavoring and like right
gonna be way too much slang that doesn't
quite make sense again so i'm a little
concerned that that's going to be kind
of grading but outside of that i'm way
more excited about this world and even
this game as a whole than i was about
the original watchdogs the other thing i
would i would add to what rob was saying
and I agree with everything he said I
really appreciated they made hacking so
much more open it felt like it was you
know you were very dependent on your
environment everything was you know if
you happen to be standing near a
particular thing that's what you could
hack that's right it use but if you
weren't near anything hackable you were
just you were screwed like you said no
options in this game you have like a
drone that you can deploy a couple
different drones you can deploy seems
like there's more stuff you can hack in
more stuff you can do when you hack it
is it gives you a lot more freedom and
makes that mechanic kind of more useful
and and something that will actually
make the game feel distinctive as
opposed to just being this thing that's
like shoehorned in like ah look where a
hacker gaming yeah no not really it's
such a good point just like that was the
problem with the first one was it was
very much one-off hacking abilities yeah
like everything was contextual roadblock
in the middle of a street now it seems
like you can do a lot of combinations
with different hacking abilities like
you said with the drone like I can get
to you know somewhere that would not be
possible for me to do on foreign get
here easier where I can combo I mean
yeah you know frame this cop while i
Hotwire his car like freezing cops huh
yes I'm so dumb i'm great just like no
it's hilarious we we went to the police
academy together i thought i knew this
guy uh you know just situations just
seems funny what was the other thing you
could also uh inform like the like a
local gang that like this person you
know frame some like a wolf I'm just
gonna frame everyone is
we play that game just subject show
funny about that like never hijack a car
never to just go around like ruining
people's lives and misinformation this
is a funny thing of people like some
gang guy on his phone like oh [ __ ]
social took a bunch of coke like text on
his phone constantly will just then go
to that person and kill them or like
sorta whole scene the mill the street
like just standing there goodness sound
so funny I just realize it'll be really
interesting to compare watchdogs and
mafia because those are sort of the two
big open world third-person story-driven
like they're very similar at least on
paper I mean thematically in the story
they're trying to tell very very
different but like mechanically in terms
of the game they're trying to be very
similar so I think that'll be an
interesting showdown this holiday season
I know I'm super curious about both
games like how gunplay and like actions
gonna play into it all because it seems
like they're playing with really cool
concepts and themes but then it's like
this de facto sort of like action stuff
thrown into like satisfy part of the
audience that's one goes during the
whole game's gonna fall apart I mean
that's okay that we struggle for GTA
four years right yeah I can like yeah I
can crack that shiny veneer in such a
way that's like oh you know it stands
out like a sore thumb totally I guess
we'll find out only is there any other
games you guys are looking forward to I
mean there's there's honestly a lot
coming give me one more civ I'm
excessive I've got a big civilization
van for a very long time I'm really
excited about the changes they made in
civ kind of like with gears I appreciate
just the direction they're taking it the
ideas that they've tried to imbue in
this in this new iteration just like
unstacking the cities and the hidden
agendas all these different mechanics
that have now been layered on top that
are gonna I hope and I think infest
according to Mike my hardy are going to
change the way that the game plays in a
kind of fundamental way without totally
altering the the franchise's DNA right
um so I'm excited to see how that pans
out I have a lot of faith in that team
they clearly know what they're doing so
I'm excited for more civ and I'm excited
that it's something a little different
it's not just like a blockbuster shooter
which seems to be a big you know chunk
of the games to come out at this time of
year so that could be a really cool
break from some of the other stuff we're
getting discount a season there's a lot
of shoot-'em-ups coming out yeah
yeah lots guns as every year yeah i will
say that i will definitely play uh
infinite warfare campaign like yeah it
looks pretty good yeah dude space dog
fighting it's fun i'll try that i hope
that works uh yeah it's worth it i get
all t i'll try it yeah the hell I want
it to be good that's a good point like
man if I want back but I want dog
fighting I want one to one I wonder it
controlling my own roles if it's like
super on Rails just like hold the
trigger down and just fire away like get
me back get me out of here give me on
foot [ __ ] what are you gonna hack
enemy ships and tell them about all
those coke deals I want to frame someone
Peter what has you so excited about a
Last Guardian that's so interesting hear
you say that because I feel like that
has fallen off of a lot of people's
radars like it was it's been in
development for so long now that we
finally seen any people are kind of like
yeah whatever and it seems like it's
moment is kind of past but apparently
not for you so why are you still psyched
about it moments don't pass for me when
it comes to games that I haven't had a
chance to play and no this is something
that you know seriously was announced
back win Fumito away to the developer of
eco shut other classes now this was at
the peak of his career and this seemed
to be the next step in his evolution as
a developer to dramatize the whole thing
this Final Four yes and so we know we've
we've seen people play the game and
we've seen their reactions and it sounds
kind of middling but a lot of things
they describe our sort of part and
parcel of shadow of the colossus in the
way it controls the way to animates and
I'm okay with that hmm I do think it may
stand out in today's modern era where
things are maybe a little bit more tight
unless you know floaty but again that's
a style that I'm I've accepted in the
past and I maybe I embrace older games
more than most folks but I do think that
there's a chance that that well that
won't ruin the game for me so I put that
aside and what I'm left with is my
initial sense of wonder at what can you
wait us on do to really surprise me
again and I just don't know and so that
is why I'm so interested in seeing it
there are ads on buses now that game is
frickin coming out so it's coming so I
feel like I'm ready to actually be
excited to be curious and I'm a little
sad that it comes at the tail end of the
season though because I think people are
going to be so
husted police on RN from so many games
and even for consumers they've probably
spent a lot of money up until that point
yeah and I think a similar fate is
something that found in fantasy 15 faces
another game it's been development for a
long time they'll this one has changed
hands and it seems to be coming together
it's evolved a lot since the two demos
that we've had a chance to play but you
know final fantasy as much as I love it
it can excuse me for saying it can be
too far up it's on but sometimes to the
point heater it you know it loses maybe
sight of the things that the audience
really loves and it's sort of trying to
tell the audience what they should love
a lot of games fault you know have that
problem but final fantasy 13 exhibited
those issues quite a bit now again
development is sort of changed hands and
this is not the same team they made 13
by any measure but you know there's been
some things like this sort of like that
the top-heavy girl whose shirt is
unbuttoned right that's the sort of
thing where it's like that shouldn't be
important to either emphasize or defend
and if that's the thing they're going to
stick with plus all these like fashion
things tacked on top of it I wonder
where their priorities are hmm so I'm
glad to see that it's improved I'm
cautious to see that it's doing some
things that don't really matter to me
and I think a lot of people and so
company again you combine those two
things and it's like what will this be
what can it turn out to be and while the
pleasure of finding out in a November I
guess fingers crossed yeah this stage it
is interesting that those are both
coming a little later on I know but at
least nice thing i would i would say
about you a disans games as they tend to
be kind of timeless so you know people
miss it you know this December I'd like
that kind of experience has has legs and
and could still be something beautiful
and enjoyable assuming the game come
came together yeah you know just as much
next year's would be this year so
hopefully as it should be right yeah
yeah and hopefully doesn't get
completely overlooked but even if it
does to some extent I think that that
will you know as with shadow the classes
become you know at least find a cult
following if nothing else yeah all right
those are the games we are looking
forward to throughout the rest of the
year let us know what you are looking
forward to in the comments below